let's try to find the limit as x
approaches one of x to the third minus
one over x squared minus one and at
first when you just try to substitute x
equals one you get zero over zero one
minus one over one minus one so that
doesn't help us so let's see if we can
try to simplify this in some way
so you might immediately recognize so
let's
rewrite this expression right over here
so it's x to the third minus one over x
squared minus one
this on the bottom immediately jumps out
as a difference of squares so no we know
on the bottom that this could be
factored as
x minus 1
times x plus 1.
and so if we could if somehow this thing
on the top also has an x minus 1 as a
factor then that x minus 1 will cancel
with this and then we're not going to
have an issue of dividing by 0. the
reason why i care about the x minus 1
term is that this is what's making our
denominator equal 0. when you say x
equals one you have one minus one times
one plus one so zero times two it's the
zero that's making our denominator zero
so if we can have an x minus one up here
then they then they can then we can
cancel these out for any x not equal to
one and then we might have a
a much simpler thing to find the limit
of
so let's think about whether x to the
third minus one is the product of x
minus one and something else and to do
that we can do a little bit of algebraic
long division some of you guys might
already recognize a pattern here but
we'll try to do we'll let's divide x
minus 1 into it to see
to see what
whether it divides evenly into x to the
third minus 1.
so x minus 1 we just look at the highest
degree term x goes into x to the third x
squared times
goes x squared times actually let me do
it this way so that we we can keep track
of the place so this would be the x this
would be the second degree place first
degree place and this would be the
constant so x to the third minus one
x goes into x to the third x squared
times x squared times x is x to the
third x squared times negative one is
minus
x squared now we're going to want to
subtract this
so we are then left with
x squared
x goes into x squared x times
plus x
x times x is x squared x times minus 1
is minus x and once again we're going to
subtract this we'll swap the signs
negative and positive
and so these cancel out and we're left
with x and then we bring down a
minus one x minus one goes into x minus
one exactly one time one times x minus
one is x minus one and then you subtract
and then you have no remainder so this
numerator right over here can be
factored as x minus 1
times x squared plus x plus 1.
and so we can say that this is the same
exact thing we can have these cancel out
if we assume x does not equal one so
that is equal to x squared plus x plus
one
over x plus one
for
x does not equal
x does not equal one and that's
completely fine because we're not
evaluating it x equals 1. we're
evaluating as x approaches 1. so this is
going to be the same thing as the limit
as x approaches 1
of
x squared
plus x plus 1
over x plus 1.
and now this is much easier to
to find you could literally just say
well what happens when as we get right
to x equals 1 then you have 1 squared
which is one plus one plus one which is
three
over one plus one which is two so we get
that equaling three halves